hello everyone we're so glad you've
joined us for this live webinar
uncertainty choice and dopamine I am
soon family roots and I'll be moderating
today's session today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning let's get
started you can pose questions to the
speaker during the presentation at any
time while they're fresh in your mind to
do so simply type them in the Q&A box
which will open when you click the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience any technical problem seeing
or hearing this presentation click on
the support button found at the bottom
of the top right of the presentation
window or report your problem by
clicking on the green Q&A button lower
left this is an educational webinar and
thus offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over please
click on the CD button located at the
bottom left hand corner of your webpage
and follow the process of obtaining your
credits I would like now to present
today's speaker speaker dr. Stan
Florescu
dr. slam Orosco is a professor of
psychology and member of the brain
research Center at the University of
British Columbia and a fellow of the
American College of
neuropsychopharmacology with over 90
peer-reviewed publications dr. fresco
specializes in research on behavioral
and neural physiological approaches with
30 neuro circuits within the dopamine
system that facilitate higher order
cognitive functions such as cognitive
flexibility and cost benefit
decision-making he's also interested in
how dysfunction in these circuits may
relate to psychiatric disease in 2010
dr. fresco was awarded the American
Psychological associations Early Career
Award I will now turn it over to dr.
Flores over his presentation
thank you to our boots for inviting me
to give this talk and for all you
joining us online thank you and for
those of you who are watching this on
demand later glad you could make it so
today I'd like to talk to you about some
what my colleagues and I have been
focusing on over the last 10 years or so
now looking at different neural circuits
within the dopamine system and how they
regulate certain aspects of reward
seeking within the context of risk
reward decision-making now life
routinely presents us with situations
where we have to choose between
different options that may yield us
different types of reward these rewards
can differ in terms of their subjective
value choosing between two things we
like we just happen to like one more
than the other Godiva's chocolate versus
her she needs craft beer versus
Budweiser or what have you or they can
differ in terms of their objective value
basically more versus less reward and
all things being equal we tend to like
larger versus small rewards but the
decisions that will wrestle with that
give us pause or when these larger or
better rewards are associated with some
sort of costs that can diminish the
subjective value of objectively larger
rewards and these costs can take a
variety of forms sometimes we may have
to work a little harder or wait a little
longer to obtain the things that we
prefer orders will be the focus of my
talk sometimes these larger or better
rewards might be associated with some
sort of uncertainty or risk and we might
not always get rewarded for choosing a
certain course of action now these types
of decisions are particularly tricky
because here you have to do the
long-term cost-benefit math and try to
ascertain well maybe I will always get
rewarded if I choose a certain course of
action but will be more beneficial for
me in the long term if I play a little
more risky or a little more conservative
now studies on the neural basis of risk
reward decision-making really find their
roots in the mid 90s with the pioneering
work of Antonio Damasio and Anton Bashar
who devised a novel task we now refer to
as the Iowa gambling task that was
designed to tap into
world decision-making in terms of
uncertainty rewards costs and
punishments now since those original
studies with the advent of new tasks use
of functional imaging and we're looking
at different patient populations we now
know the different aspects of risk
reward decision-making are mediated by
distributed neural circuits in the brain
that link different regions of the
frontal lobes the amygdala which resides
in the temporal lobes and the ventral
portion of the striatum also known as
the nucleus accumbens and one thing that
all these regions have in common in
addition to their own interconnectivity
is that they're all also connected with
a Meisel cortical limbic dopamine system
which suggests that dopamine may also
play a role in these functions so we've
known for nearly half a century that
dopamine plays some role in reward
although admittedly those of us who
study this molecule can't always agree
exactly what its function is with
respect to dopamine neurons one thing we
know about these cells is that their
electrical activity is particularly
sensitive to situations involving the
presence or absence of expected or
unexpected rewards so if one records the
activity of dopamine neurons in an awake
behaving animal and they present them
with either rewards or cues associated
with those rewards once there's a
characteristic pattern of activity so if
we take an animal and present it with an
unexpected reward what that does is that
causes these dopamine neurons to fire a
brief phasic burst in activity to
increase their activity whereas if we
now start giving the animal some
information about those rewards present
a certain cue that reliably predicts
that the reward is coming eventually
these dopamine neurons actually start to
fire in response to that cue associated
with reward but not necessarily the
reward itself on the other hand let's
say we present the animal with a cue
associated with that reward but then
when the animal is expecting reward
we don't actually deliver it well in
that case we actually see a suppression
in dopamine neuron activity what we
refer to sometimes as a phasic dip
and so these increases in decreases in
dopamine neuron activity associated with
expected or unexpected rewards or non
rewarding events are thought to encode
what are referred to as reward
prediction errors which may help an
animal organize its behavior and change
its actions when it's not getting what
it expects to do or promote consumer
action towards getting these rewards now
it seems that dopamine neurons are also
particularly sensitive to situations
involving reward uncertainty because we
can change the scenario that I just
described you here now we can present
the animal with a variety of different
cues
some cues are never associated with
reward there's a zero percent chance of
getting a reward when that cue is
presented while another cue might always
be associated with war 100 percent
chance and then there may be some cues
which only deliver the rewards a certain
portion of the time 25 50 75 percent of
the time and these are seminal data from
Wolfram Schultz as group and what they
found in this study is that the activity
of dopamine neurons in response to these
different cues was maximal in response
to the cues that presented the maximal
amount of reward uncertainty so that
dopamine neuron activity was much
greater when the animal was presented
with the cue that suggested he might get
a reward 50% of the time when you
compare that to cues that either always
predictable warned or that never
predicted reward so this suggests that
the entire dopamine system is
particularly ticklish when the organism
is not quite sure whether or not they're
going to get a reward now studies and
humans have been monumental in helping
us identify some of the different
systems that may be involved in using
this information to guide
decision-making but they don't really
allow us the experimental control we
need in order to understand the
mechanisms underlying the processes that
help guide our behavior when we have to
choose between different rewards of
different probabilities so we really
need to turn to the animal model to help
understand how these different systems
may interact and what their specific
roles may be in guiding risk reward
and so what by our group have been using
an assay that is referred to as a
probabilistic discounting test where we
get animals to choose between different
types of rewards varying in terms of
their magnitude and their relative
certainty so I'm going to spend a bit of
time discussing this assay because most
of the data I'll be showing you today
was using this basic type of task so
this task is conducted in an operant
chamber and the way this game works is
on any given trial we present the animal
with two options two levers if the
animal chooses what we call the small
certainly permit it always gets this
smaller one pellet reward so this is the
safe Canadian government savings bond
option you're not always going to get
that much of a return but you'd always
guaranteed some return on your
investment now on the other hand on this
trial the animal might choose what we
call the large risky leaver here the
animal may or may not get the larger
floor pellet reward and the probability
of the animal getting this reward
changes in a systematic manner over
blocks of trials within a daily session
and so the way we typically run this
game is at the start of the session the
odds of getting the reward are very high
either a hundred or fifty percent and
then as the session progresses the odds
get leaner and leader to fifty twenty
five then in 12.5 percent chance of the
animal getting that large reward and
changes in these reward probabilities
are signaled by blocks of forced choice
trials before every block of free choice
trial so first in every block would give
the end when we force the animal to
choose either one of believers and then
this way it can ascertain what the
relative probability of them obtaining
that reward is then we give them a
period of free choice trials where both
leavers are presented and now they have
to choose based on the information we
gave them richly when they prefer which
one they think is the better option for
them and if you take a look at this
graph here after about twenty something
days of training I always become
relatively rational decision makers on
this town's
choosing that risky option more when
reward probabilities are high and then
choosing it less when the rule of
probabilities
so what all the studies I'll be talking
about today
animals were well trained on this game
so by the time we did our neural
manipulations there were experienced
players and within any group of animals
we have some animals that are tend to be
more risky and some animals that tend to
play more conservative and so we would
use a within subjects design to see how
when they alter different nodes of
dopamine circuitry how does that alter
the way they play the game on that
particular day and so in our initial
studies looking at how dopamine might be
involved we simply did systemic
treatments with different drugs that
interfere with dopamine transmission one
of the first things we found that is
that if we increase dopamine release by
giving a drug like amphetamine we get
this market increase in risky choice
animals were much slower to update the
changes in their decision bias and they
persisted in playing that risky option
even though the odds were getting poorer
and poorer on the other hand if we
reduced dopamine transmission by giving
a drug that blocks dopamine receptors
such as flu pain fix all we see the
opposite change in behavior now animals
actually played much more conservative
they were risk averse they didn't like
choosing that large risky option they
would rather she was that smaller but
safer reward suggesting that dopamine
Tahlia in the brain helps biased rows
towards these larger uncertain rewards
so these data told us that dopamine
somewhere in the brain might be helping
modify these decision biases when
animals choose between risky versus
certain options so over the last few
years we've systematically targeted
different nodes within the dopamine
system to try to understand what their
functional contribution to these
problems are and in these experiments
before we started playing with dopamine
we just simply used reversible and
activations of different nuclei where we
could temporarily shut down neural
activity in these different regions to
kind of ascertain what role do they play
in guiding decisions what do they bring
to the table in terms of helping to
solve these types of problems
what I'm showing you here is a cartoon
showing some of the neural circuits that
we've looked at over the last few years
and showing their intrinsic connectivity
so you can see one nucleus the
basolateral amygdala which resides in
the temporal lobes and is important for
emotional processing it sends
projections to the nucleus accumbens the
bezawada amygdala also shares reciprocal
connections with the medial prefrontal
cortex in the frontal lobes and this
cortical region also sends projections
to the striatum so I'm going to
summarize about six years worth of data
in the next 90 seconds or so just to
show you what our studies within
activations have shown what these
different regions contribute so what we
found is that one circuit linking the
basal lateral amygdala to the nucleus
accumbens seems to play a key role in
biasing choice towards these larger
uncertain rewards because if we in
activate either structure bilaterally or
if we disconnect communication between
these two structures we get a market
decrease in risky choice similar to what
we see when we block dopamine receptors
so this region is the one that is
promoting choice of these large you're
uncertain rewards for those of you who
play poker this is the part of the brain
that lights up when you have a pair of
kings in your hands and is saying go
all-in chase after that big reward but
these urges to play more risky are
tempered by the frontal lobes and this
particular region of the prefrontal
cortex the medial region analogous to
area 32 of the anterior cingulate in
humans seems to play a more cognitive
role in helping adjust decision biases
and keeping track of actions and
outcomes over multiple trials to help
ascertain what the relative beneficial
action is what are the relative odds
between these different options and one
of the reasons I say that is because if
we inactivate the medial prefrontal
cortex when the odds are initially good
at the start of the session and then get
poor as the session progresses we see an
increase in risky choice and must keep
accusing that risky option even though
it's not as benefit
to do so however if we change the game a
little bit and have another group of
animals where the odds are initially
poor at the start of the session start
at 12.5% and then get progressively
better in activation of the prefrontal
cortex actually causes the opposite
pattern of effect animals are slower to
update their decision biases and overall
choose less risky so what we think the
prefrontal cortex does in this situation
is it monitors changes in reward
contingencies that in turn helps the
animal change its behavior alter its
decision biases when things are changing
in its environment so one thing we were
really interested in seeing well how do
some of these circuits talk to each
other are they working independently of
each other or are they actually
cooperating sending information back and
forth to help refine these decision
biases and we were particularly
interested in understanding whether the
amygdala and the prefrontal cortex
interact directly to guide
decision-making now when we do a
bilateral activation shutting down both
regions of a nucleus in in one brain
that will tell you that nucleus is
involved in a certain behavior but it
won't tell you who it's talking to what
other nuclei might be interacting with
but one way we can delineate the roots
of information transfer between brain
regions is by using a relatively
old-school traditional technique called
an asymmetrical or disconnection
inactivation procedure now the rationale
behind this procedure rests on two
assumptions first it assumes that for
any given behavior information may be
transmitted from one structure in this
example structure a to another structure
structure B on both sides of the brain
in parallel furthermore it assumes that
a unilateral inactivation of any
structure by itself should have no great
effect on behavior because you will
still have a contra lateral circuit
available on the other side of the brain
so what we do in this asymmetrical
disconnection procedure is on one side
of the brain we use a unilateral
inactivation
the output structure and then we combine
that with a contralateral inactivation
of the receiving structure downstream so
what this selectively does is it
prevents communication between this a
and B circuit on both sides of the brain
so in this example on the left side of
the brain structure B can't process
information from structure a because we
have that inactivation upstream on the
right side of the brain structure a is
intact but now structure B can't process
any information being transmitted from
structure a because structure B has been
inactivated so if we need selective
communication in this circuit then this
type of asymmetrical disconnection
should disrupt behavior but let's say
that structure E is not talking the
structure B let's say it started talking
to another structure say structure see
well in this case we would not expect a
big effect on behavior because we would
still have a free circuit on one side of
the brain so we use this procedure to
ascertain whether the amygdala and the
prefrontal cortex form a functional
circuit to help guide decision-making
and so as you can see here the data when
we just infuse saline as a control
procedure animals showed rational
pattern of decision making choosing the
larger reward more when the odds were
good and choosing it less when the odds
were bad now when we conducted an
ipsilateral inactivation so when we
disconnected communication between the
amygdala and the prefrontal cortex only
on one side of the brain we got no
change in behavior but it's when we
disconnected communication on both sides
of the brain between these structures
while we saw profound change now to be
quite honest we weren't sure what was
going to happen here because as you may
recall when we bilaterally and activated
either structure either the amygdala or
the prefrontal cortex we actually got
opposing effects on behavior when we
inactivated the prefrontal cortex
animals chose more risky and we're
slower to update their decision biases
whereas when we inactivated the amygdala
analysts played more concern
so we weren't sure if a disconnection
might just cancel both of these effects
out or we might get a different pattern
of behavior well it turns out when we
selectively disrupt prefrontal amygdala
communications we get a prefrontal light
phenotype again animals were more risky
they were slower to update their
behavior they kept choosing that risky
option even though the odds were getting
poorer and poorer over the course of the
session suggesting that these two
regions are communicating to help refine
decision bias and modify action
selection when there are changes in
reward contingencies now one thing we do
in these types of studies is we do a
more fine detailed analysis of the
behavior try to understand
well why exactly our animals playing
more or less risky and so we do it
curious by choice analysis to see well
are they playing more risky because
maybe they like the rewards better so we
can look at Wynnstay behavior looking at
the probability of them choosing the
risky option after playing risky on the
previous trial in winning and in this
case that process didn't seem to be
effective instead the reason the animals
seemed to be playing more risky is that
they were less sensitive to losses we
saw a decrease in what we termed their
lose shift behavior so normally what an
animal plays risky and loses on a trial
doesn't get that reward we see them
shift to the more conservative option on
the next trial about 30 to 40 percent of
the time when we prevented the amygdala
and the prefrontal cortex from talking
to each other we saw a market decrease
in this lose shift behavior as if the
animals either were unaware or didn't
care that they were losing more as a
session progresses so they kept playing
risky now as I told you this pathway is
reciprocally connected and even though I
don't have time to go into the details
of the data we have done some follow-up
experiments where we have identified
that this effect where we see a
disruption in choice behavior when we
disconnect the prefrontal cortex and the
amygdala is actually mediated through a
descending pathway
we're the prefrontal cortex it seems to
it seems to exert top-down control over
the amygdala so these signals seem to
originate in the frontal lobes and then
they send their mediating influence over
choice behavior that is normally driven
by amygdala ventral striatum circuits so
when we take these data and kind of
integrate it into a kind of model
circuit diagram that we are building to
help understand how these different
regions interact to guide behavior but
when the animal is choosing between
different options we have one circuit
this subcortical more visceral circuit
linking the amygdala and the ventral
striatum that is biasing choice towards
these larger uncertain rewards as if to
say free ride set go after that big
reward
but these urges are tempered by the
frontal lobes whereas they used exert
top-down control over the niccola and
the prefrontal lobes keep track of
actions and outcomes over time ascertain
that hey this particular course of
action is not yielding us as much reward
as it used to
perhaps we should change our strategy
perhaps we should maybe play a little
more conservative and then it uses its
influence to suppress or mediate these
urges to chase after those big rewards
driven by these subcortical circuits and
so this is a common thing we see in
emotional regulation as well as we have
these subcortical systems that are
driving emotional responses but they are
modified and tempered by different
regions of the frontal lobe so now that
we had an idea of some of the key
hardware that the brain uses in terms of
solving these problems we were
interested in seeing some of the
software that let being involved in
these processes namely how dopamine may
play a role and in these studies what we
did was simple straightforward
psychopharmacological studies where we
would administer small volumes of drugs
that interfere with dopamine
transmission in our Tukey terminal
regions here
the medial prefrontal cortex and the
nucleus accumbens
now in one study we targeted these mezzo
accumbens pathway and the results here
were relatively straightforward one
thing I can tell you is that when we
target a different dopamine receptor
subtypes so there are two key receptor
subtypes we were interested in the
dopamine d2 receptor and the d1 receptor
whereas when we blocked d2 receptors in
the accumbens we saw no real change in
choice behavior
now these doses were behaviorally active
animals were slower to make choices they
moved less in the chamber but disrupting
d2 receptor transmission didn't seem to
affect their general pattern of choice
behavior instead the big player in the
accumbens seemed to be the d1 receptor
because when we blocked these receptors
we saw a decrease in risky choice
animals chose that risky option much
less and in this instance the reason
they were playing more conservative the
reason they were more risk-averse was
this manipulation caused an increased
sensitivity to losses so when they
played risky and they lost they were now
more likely to switch to the
conservative option on the next trial in
opposition to what we saw when we
disrupted prefrontal amygdala circuitry
so these data suggest that within the
ventral striatum for the nucleus
accumbens the d1 receptor plays a key
role in mitigating sensitivity losses
and promoting choice towards these
larger uncertain rewards now and the
prefrontal cortex the story was a little
bit more complicated here we also
targeted these two key dopamine receptor
subtypes and when we blocked dopamine to
d2 receptors here we saw an increase in
risky choice very similar to what we see
when we inactivated prefrontal cortex
and so when we took these receptors out
of the equation when Dilton was not
allowed to signal through these
receptors animals again persisted in
choosing that risky option even though
the odds were changing so we interpret
these data to mean that one function of
dopamine d2 receptors in the frontal
lobes may facilitate X
raishin of different options when
rewards changes because when we enacted
that when we block these receptors
animals are slower to start exploring
new options when the reward
probabilities decrease over time now
what we were particularly taken back was
when we blocked opening d1 receptors we
actually saw the opposite changing
behavior from when we brought d2
receptors animals again were more
risk-averse similar what we saw when we
block these receptors in the accumbens
and again they were more sensitive to
losses if they played risky and they
lost after we bought the e1 receptors
they were more likely to switch to that
conservative options so we interpret
this to mean that d1 receptors are
playing a distinct yet complementary
role - what DT receptors are doing in
the prefrontal cortex and these
receptors may facilitate exploitation of
currently favourable circumstances so
the idea is when the animal plays risky
and loses activity at d1 receptor sites
may help bridge the gap between rewarded
and non rewarded actions as if to
facilitate the ability of the system to
say hey you didn't win on this
particular trial but keep at it
because it may be more profitable in the
long term
don't be so disruptive because you
didn't win on this trial it might be
better for you to keep at this risky
option so as a psychologist we loved
associations we loved it when two brain
systems are showing an opposite changes
in behavior but this is a weird one when
you think about because the brain
doesn't release a d1 or d2 receptor
agonist it releases dopamine which would
be expected distinguish both receptors
so how does the same neurotransmitter
system working in the same brain region
mediate different patterns of Believer
seemingly opposite patterns of behavior
just by working on different receptors
so for that we wear eyes were kind of
reopen to the idea in some recent
studies that came out in 2012
showed that there actually appeared to
be separate populations of projection
neurons within the prefrontal cortex
that only expressed d1 or only expressed
d2 receptors so we have what appears to
be separate circuits that are only
modulated by one receptor or the other
and so this may be how dopamine may be
able to exert differential effects when
we take one receptor out of the equation
or the other by working on separate
micro circuits now we follow these
experiments up with some other studies
trying to see whether these different
circuits may have different projection
targets and I won't have time to show
you today today but what it looks to be
going on is that maybe we may have one
circuit of a remember of prefrontal
neurons that contain d2 receptors that
project to the amygdala that mediate one
parameters that mediate exploration of
new options that facilitate changes in
decision biases whereas another circuit
made up of neurons that contain
primarily d1 receptors may be
interacting with a separate sub cortical
nucleus in this case the ventral
striatum to promote exploitation of
currently favorable circumstances so
those of us who study dopamine and are
hoping to find a grand unified theory of
its function
well these data suggest that our task is
a little bit harder because even when
we're looking at just one single brain
region it seems that within a particular
brain region dopamine may be doing
different things and facilitating
different cognitive operations and
patterns of behavior by working on
distinct sub circuits or ensembles of
neurons and these neurons can differ in
terms of the specific dopamine receptors
that they express and their particular
projection targets so as we continue to
try to understand how our dopamine may
be involved in cognition and behavior
we're going to have to account for the
fact that we have separate groups of
cells even within one particular brain
region that may be promoting quite
different patterns of behavior
so these studies showed us that dopamine
clearly played an important role in
facilitating modifications and decision
biases and promoting choice are larger
riskier rewards we were particularly
interested in seeing how the changes in
dopamine release relate to changes in
the animal's behavior the dopamine level
just go up and stay up or are there
other dynamic fluctuations in dopamine
transmission before we get to those
studies
I just want to integrate these dopamine
data here with this emergent circuit
that we're talking so we have our
prefrontal amygdala striatal circuits
and within this circuit dopamine seems
to be doing different things in
different brain regions and acting on
different dopamine receptors d1
receptors in both the prefrontal cortex
and the nucleus accumbens seem to reduce
the sensitivity to non reward actions
and promote and maintain choice biases
so it helps an organism keep that eye on
the prize maybe you didn't win this time
but keep at it because it might be more
profitable in the long term
whereas d2 receptors in the prefrontal
cortex seem to facilitate changes and
decision biases and promote exploration
of new options and within the prefrontal
cortex as I said d1 and d2 receptors may
mediate different aspects of reward
seeking by acting on dissent distinct
ensembles of pre frontal projection
neurons that may have distinct
subcortical projection targets so how do
dopamine levels change when animals are
engaging in these behaviors well to do
this we collaborate with my former PhD
supervisor Tony Phillips and his
long-term Research Associates soy Anton
and we used in vivo micro dialysis which
permitted us to look at fluctuations in
tonic dopamine levels in these different
terminal regions while animals were
actually performing and playing the game
and these experiments animals were again
well trained on the task and a lot of
tests did we would implant them with
micro Dallas's probes in either the
prefrontal cortex or the nucleus
accumbens
so we could see how dope Nina was
chained there were different phases of
the task and in this task we were able
to use a sampling interval of seven
minutes why do I bring that up
well this relatively short sampling
interval would allow us to look at
changes in dopamine release during the
forced-choice portion of each block so
when animals were only presented with
one lever so it didn't actually have to
make a decision just had to respond on
whatever option we gave them and then
compare that to changes in dopamine
release during the free choice portions
of the sessions where they actually had
to make a choice and in these
experiments we had separate groups of
animals on the train where the odds
initially were good at the start of the
session and named up or changed from a
hundred percent to 12.5% and our groups
of animals where the odds were initially
poor at the start of the session and
then not better started at 12.5% and
progressively increased now we needed a
key control experiment in these tasks
because anyone who knows anything about
dopamine is just that the mere
consumption of shrewdest is enough to
turn this system on so if we see changes
in dopamine release when rats are
engaged in decision-making we need it to
a certain well how much of this signal
is driven by them actually having to
make decisions and evaluations versus
the mere consumption of food so in these
experiments we included a key gilt food
control experiment animals in these
groups they didn't have to press any
levers they don't have to make any
decisions what happened with them is on
any given trial every 40 seconds the
house lights came on and they would
receive either four pellets one pellet
or zero pellets and the scheduling and
amount of rewards they received during
these sessions were matched identically
to animals that had actually performed
the task so here we could control for
the amount and the scheduling of food
that they received so in these groups
animals were just basically receiving
food for free
have to work for their dinner they would
just get this food but they got it on
the exact same schedule as an animal
that actually had to work for its supper
and had to make decisions in terms of
how having to maximize its rewards so if
you all start with what we saw in the
prefrontal cortex and one thing I can
tell you is that when we looked at
animals where the odds went from good to
bad and compare that when the odds went
from bad to good
we saw mirror image profiles of each
other and we were able to combine the
data and when we plot these data in
terms of changes in prefrontal dopamine
release ends a function of reward
probability you can see in these green
circles here that dopamine levels were
higher when the probability of obtaining
that larger reward was hired and then
they were lower when the odds of getting
these four pallets were lower so one of
the first things we noticed about this
change in the dopamine signal is that it
didn't really map on very well to
changes in the animals behavior what
these white circles are showing you here
is how often animals actually chose the
large risky option over the course of
the session and as you can see the king
who choice behavior didn't really mirror
the change in the dopamine signal
instead what it looked like was the
change in prefrontal dopamine levels and
the signals from the dopamine system
that the frontal lobes are receiving
mapped on very well to changes in how
much food how much reward the animal was
receiving over time what these triangles
are showing you is the relative amount
of reward pellets animals received over
the session and as you can see here the
slope of the change in the amount of
food they received looking in that curve
was practically identical to changes in
the amount of dopamine that would being
released over these comparable sessions
and what's more when we looked at the
data from our animals in the yolked
group animals that didn't press any
levers that didn't make any decisions
and simply got the same amount of food
in the same
for free we saw a near identical profile
again dopamine levels were higher when
they were getting more food and then
lower when they were getting less food
so what this suggests to us is that
fluctuations in prefrontal dopamine
levels seem to be keeping track of how
much reward animals are receiving over
time serving the sort of a reward
running rate meter and if you think
about what the prefrontal cortex might
be doing in these types of situations
keeping track of actions and outcomes
over time to help modify behavior the
system didn't need some sort of
information to kind of update over a
longer term period of how are we doing
in terms of our profits are we getting
more or less reward over time to help
modify behavior these data suggest that
changes in dopamine transmission in the
frontal lobes may be one such input to
this region that the prefrontal cortex
uses to help adjust behavior in the
accumbens the story was a little bit
more complicated we again saw that
dopamine levels were higher when reward
probabilities were higher and then lower
when the odds of getting those rewards
were less but the profile looked quite
different to what we saw in the
prefrontal cortex the first thing we
notice here was changes and accumbens
dopamine levels mapped on almost
perfectly the changes in the animals
behavior so the rate of change in
dopamine release over the course of the
session was pretty much the same as the
rate in change of how often the animal
chose those risky options now the other
thing I'd like to point out here is you
see in this profile looking at the green
circles you see this sawtooth profile
when dopamine levels are lower and then
they go up a bit then the lower are
going up a bit again with these
oscillations in dopamine represent our
changes in dopamine release during the
forced-choice portions of each bronc
compared to the fructose portions where
the animals actually have to make a
decision and as it turns out when the
animals actually have to choose dopamine
levels are just a little bit higher then
when the animals simply have to
make a response don't have any choice in
the matter and just have to press a
single lever so the system seems to turn
a little bit more when the animals
actions and their choices have a direct
outcome of what they might be receiving
now in comparison changes in dopamine
release in the accumbens did not map on
very well to changes in the amount of
root word they received over time as I'm
showing you in these red triangles here
but we still conducted our guilt food
control its lemon here we saw an
interesting profile what these squares
are showing you here is changes in
dopamine release in animals that got the
exact same amount of reward and the same
pattern of rewards as animals have
played the task and what I want you to
notice here is that when at these posts
of the sessions don't be levels weren't
comparable but then the curves separate
at this point here what is special about
that point there is that these are the
portions of the task where the animals
have to make a choice and there is on
some uncertainty about the option they
may not get rewarded for those choices
in the early part of the session here
they're either always guaranteed to get
some reward either a larger or smaller
reward or have no choice in the matter
but as soon as we have the situations
where now the animals have to choose and
they might not get a reward when they
chose a certain action dopamine levels
were higher when we compare that to
animals that just got this food for free
so the system seems to be more engaged
when the animal has to make a choice and
the animal is not entirely sure whether
or not their choices might lead them to
reward so what this suggests to us is
that changes in these slower tonic
levels of extra synoptic dopamine in the
ventral striatum may be integrating a
variety of different signals and provide
a long-term accounting of multiple types
of information including the animals
trust behavior what it's doing the
relative amount of uncertainty
associated with those choices I
well as changes in the amount of reward
they're receiving over time so
fluctuations in these slower tonic
dopamine levels in the accumbens seem to
be integrating multiple types of
information so when we look at doping
transmission within the striatum they
are again these slower changing levels
of dopamine that fluctuate over longer
periods many minutes but there are also
these faster phasic signals I described
to you at the beginning that are
mediated by bursts firing of dopamine
neurons now if you want to look at
dopamine release that is needed by these
bursting events of dopamine neurons
other investigators have used more rapid
watering techniques that have a higher
temporal issues such as in vivo
voltammetry and there has been a fair
amount of excellent work done by a
number of investigators using these
faster techniques to measure rapid
changes in dopamine release within the
accumbens when animals were engaged in
cost-benefit decision-making so the data
I'm showing you here are data from one
of my good friends regina Corelli and
her group and here they recorded rapid
changes in dopamine release in the
nucleus accumbens when animals were
performing a very similar game to what I
described to you here where they were
choosing between a larger uncertain and
smaller certain rewards and two things
they noticed here is that these for the
animal would make a choice a few seconds
before the animal would have to choose
between the options or make a response
we would see phasic increase in doping
release that you can see on the time
scale here lasts a few seconds rather
than changes over minutes that we were
monitoring with microdialysis and the
magnitude of this phasic increase prior
the choice was related to whether or not
the animal was permitted to choose its
more preferred
option so dopamine levels were higher
when the animals were either forced to
choose their more preferred option or
had the choice between their preferred
and less preferred option when they
compared the magnitude of release what
animals were forced to choose the option
they didn't like as much and then after
the
made a choice dopamine levels increased
again in a rapid and phasic manner and
in this instance the magnitude of the
change in dopamine release seemed to
encode the outcomes of those choices so
of animals played risky and they won get
that larger reward they saw a large
increase in dopamine release if they
chose the smaller certain option they
saw a comparably smaller increase in
dopamine release and all those times
where they played whiskey and they lost
they actually saw a decrease in building
release varied it's similar to what I
described to you in the beginning or how
dopamine yarns seem to encode reward
prediction errors showing a larger
increase when they get an unexpected
reward and showing a decrease when they
don't receive any reward so we were
interested in seeing well how might
these rapid phasic signals in dopamine
release regulate choice behavior an
action selection now we've done our
pharmacological experiments where we
would block dopamine receptors but but
those don't really tell you what these
rapid signals are when you go in with an
antagonist and block dopamine receptors
you're blocking all the types of signals
boastings rapid phasic signals and these
slower changing tonic signals for lead
for an hour or two so it doesn't really
parse out what specific information
these basic signals are so we needed a
way to use a temporary precise mechanism
to suppress these phasic signals and it
turns out the Nature has provided us
with a neural circuit that exerts
inhibitory control over the dopamine
system in that circuit involves a
nucleus referred to as a lateral
habenula this is an evolutionary day or
in the nucleus we see this and all sorts
of vertebrate species and one reason
there's been a lot of interest in this
nucleus is that it seems to have a
pronounced inhibitory effect over the
firing of dopamine neurons because if
you stimulate the lateral habenula
that causes a market suppression in
dopamine neuron activity very similar to
phasic dips in activity that are
observed when an animal doesn't receive
an expected reward
now recordings from lateral habenula
neurons and awake behaving animals have
shown dit well these neurons they're the
kind of like the opposite of dopamine
neurons I like to call them dopamine
neurons from the evil parallel universe
what I mean by that is they actually
firing more when something bad happens
like the animal doesn't get an expected
rewards and they actually suppress their
activity when something good happens
like they get a reward and the number of
studies over the last ten years or so
have identified that the ability of the
habenula to suppress dopamine neuron
activity is mediated by a die synoptic
circuit where we have excitatory
projections from the habenula the then
target a relatively newly discovered
nucleus in the back of the brain called
the rostral medial tegmental nucleus or
the RMT G and turn the RMT G sends a
dense inhibitory GABAergic input to
dopamine neurons in the VTA so that
activating the habeo we can suppress
dopamine neuron activity in the VTA in a
very temporary specific manner so we
used discreet electrical stimulation of
either the habenula
or the VTA itself to modify and
overwrite these different physics
signals that are associated with
decision-making and to ask do these
outcome related in Preachers phasic
signals modify action selection during
decision-making so in one experiment we
have a situation that were well where we
had animals well trained in the task and
sometimes they would choose that risky
option and they would not get a reward
that's how life works sometimes well
what we know from previous studies that
is in these situations whether if she
was risky and lunes that causes a
suppression in dopamine neuron activity
aphasic tip so under these conditions
only when animals chose risky and lost
we would give a brief half a second
stimulation to the dopamine neurons in
the ventral tegmental area the idea here
is now we are overriding these phasic
dips are actually causing a phase and
burst
tricking the system potentially into
thinking it may have got rewarded when
it actually didn't
and what we saw in this situation is
that only when we stimulated the VTA
after a loss animals started choosing
more risky they started to behave as if
that risky option was paying off much
more than it actually was
so nudging their behavior in another
direction just by overriding these
signals that occurred when they on all
played risky and lost now on the other
hand sometimes we have a situation where
the animal would choose that risky
option and win get that larger reward
what we know is happening here in terms
of dopamine transmission is that that
causes a brief phasing burst and
dopamine neuron activities new and start
to fire for a brief period of time so
what we did in this situation is every
time the animal played risky and one got
that larger reward while the animal was
receiving what reward we would give a
few brief pulses to the lateral habenula
which as we know will suppress don't
mean your own activity and suppress
these phasic bursts so here we are
trying to overwrite these signals and
again trick the system into thinking
that maybe didn't get the reward that if
fire did and under these conditions we
saw the opposite of what we saw when we
stimulated the VTA animals chose the
risky option less started behaving as if
that risky option was not paying off as
much they were not receiving this larger
work even though they were tasting the
food consuming the food their behavior
when we suppress these phasic bursts
that occurred with receipt reward seemed
to suggest that they were not
registering those wins and they just
their behavior thinking hey this is not
paying off as much now to be perfectly
honest we were having some fun with
these experiments what I was because I
wasn't actually conducting the
experiments but it was a remote
controlled the animals to a certain
degree but stimulating at a certain time
we could bias their behavior one way or
the other so we did another experiment
well what happens when we stimulate the
habenula
and suppress these phasic increases in
dopamine
when the animal chooses that small
certain option when it goes for that
safe government savings bond so now we
are simulating a crush in the bond
market
so every time we suppress dopamine
activity when the animal chose that
Smallman warden got that large a small
reward we again saw a change in behavior
here it increased risky to us animals
behaved as if well this small option is
not paying off anymore now it may be
that these effects were due to just some
aversive response they didn't like being
stimulated in the head manual and so
they are just choosing the other lever
to avoid stimulation well we don't think
that's the case because when we do a key
control experiment where animals are
just using a very simple type of
decision a large reward versus small
reward both delivered at 100% certainty
and if we stimulated the habenula every
time they got the large reward in this
simple situation there was no change in
behavior so it's not like they're
getting like getting stimulated but when
we still related in situations involving
uncertainty that's when we got changes
in behavior so what these outcome
related phasic bursts and dips seem to
be doing is providing short-term
information about recently rewarded and
non rewarded actions to influence
subsequent choice behavior now what
about those pre choice signals these
increases in dopamine release that occur
read before the animal has to make a
choice well we know right before they
need to make a choice we get this large
increase in dopamine release so what we
did in another group of animals is every
time they were about to make a choice
we again similar the habenula and
suppress that pre trace increase what
happened well one thing that happened
was that it reduced the incentive
salience of believers what I mean by
that is they're not a little slower to
make a choice they didn't sing as
invigorated to go after those levers and
all you're likely to miss out on trials
and in terms of their choice behavior
when we looked at the entire group this
tended to reduce choice of that large
risky option
but when we probed some individual
differences in our group we found that
some animals tend to just always let
that risky option irrespective of the
odds they kept choosing that risky
option whether the odds were good or bad
and in these situations when we suppress
these preachers phasic signals it
uniformly reduced their preference for
that large reward other rats on the
other hand played more rationing shows
the risky option more when the odds were
good chose it less when the odds are bad
here we saw that suppression of
preachers signals tended to disrupt
their preference for their more
preferred options so they killed the
risky option less when they preferred
that option and they chose it slightly
more when they preferred the small sate
properties so we interpret these data to
mean that these increases in dopamine
release prior to the choice seem to
promote actions directed towards more
preferred rewards now dopamine doesn't
seem to be involved in actually making
the preference in deciding what's the
better option
this is mediated by these other circuits
I've been talking about the frontal
lobes the amygdala what-have-you and
dopamine helps ensure that once a
certain bias has been established that
the animal's behavior is directed
towards what is deemed a better option
now lastly I want to finish up with some
studies looking at the involvement of
the lateral habenula itself because
while stimulation has been a useful tool
for manipulating phasic signals we
wanted to see what happens when we
remove this node out of the circuit so
for those of you who aren't familiar
with the anatomy I'm showing you here
the hanya is a relatively tiny nucleus
and it's somewhat difficult to hit
surgically so my student who worked on
this calling stopper he initially did a
set of experiments and he came to my
office after he'd completed me since
then there was no effect on choice and I
said well let's check the histology
turns out there were a bunch of lovely
placements in the dorsal hippocampus
right above the haveta
so we don't need that part of the brain
to guide decision-making I said try
again came back a few months later
there's still no effects now and I
looked at the histology now we were
getting closer to our target but still
no effect try again another experiment
now he overshot now he was below the
Hebei
no effect on behavior and we were
getting a little frustrated at this
point because that what does it take to
hit this nucleus now finally after about
a year of trying my student was able to
amass enough placements within the
target nucleus and what did we see well
rather simple-minded Li we thought that
if the head venue is telling you what's
bad in the environment then if we will
activate this nucleus we might have a
situation where animals just don't
recognize they're losing and they keep
choosing more risky but we saw something
much more profound when we inactivated
as nucleus we completely abolished any
decision bias they had they went from
choosing rationally choosing risky more
when the odds were good and choosing
less when the odds were bad too random
and haphazard patterns of choice so that
as a group they were choosing both
options roughly 50% of the time behaving
as if they had no idea which was the
better option and so they were choosing
completely random now whenever you see
in effect this Magnus magnitude well
maybe they're just blind maybe they
don't know the difference between their
left part and the right part doesn't
seem to be the case because if we give
them a simple decision big reward small
reward both delivered me a hundred
percent certainty and we in activate the
habenula
there was no choice when the animals
have to choose between two words that
differ only in their objective value big
versus small the habenula doesn't seem
to be involved but as soon as there is
some sort of cost where the animal has a
subjective preference it has to use to
guide its behavior the habenula seems to
play a fundamental role in expressing
subjective choice biases so when we
integrate these last bits of information
in our model seeing that these slower
changing Tomic dopamine levels in the
prefrontal cortex and the accumbens seem
to have a long-term account of choice
and reward history prefrontal cortex
opening tracks changes and reward rates
over time whereas a comments don't mean
the tonic signal integrates information
about the amount of reward received the
relative mana risk and choice in
contrast these phasic rapid signals seem
to play a short
term accounting conveying short-term
information about the outcomes of
choices and then promoting actions
directed towards more preferred rewards
and within this entire circuit the
lateral habenula seems to be a key
linchpin around with these cortical
striatal limbic systems and the dopamine
systems to work in a coordinated manner
because when we suppress activity in
this new place it slows the entire
system and disarray animals don't know
what the better option is in behave
random suggesting that this evolutionary
old nucleus plays a key role in enabling
expression of subjective choice
preferences with that I would like to
thank this great students I've had over
the years I've had a number of talented
hard-working as you can see here
photogenic students those who have shown
the pictures here are those who
contribute directly to the experiments
along with a number of other students
I've had over the years and this is a
recent shot of my wonderful lab here and
I'd like to thank you all for joining me
online I will now take any questions in
the Q&A box which can be found in the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
your presentation window will answer as
many questions as we have time for today
so the first question while we're
waiting for audience members to
formulate their questions if I could
could you ask if I could ask question
could you comment on the how this
function in the dopamine circuits relate
to psychiatric disorders that we see in
humans that affect human behaviors
psychiatric disorders that
that seemed to be associated with
dysfunctions in the dopamine system and
so one thing that our data showed that
and we are building on a vast literature
of people who look for this type of work
is that dopamine activity seems to
signal important events in the
environment and may increase the
likelihood of an organism engaging in
similar behaviors that lead to this
increase in dopamine and so if we have a
situation where we have excessive
increases in dopamine release like we
might see in drug addiction or in
schizophrenia this aberrant increase in
dopamine transmission may in the example
of addiction may promote individuals to
continue to engage in drug seeking
behavior in response to cues or what
happen and allow them to or kind of make
it harder for them to stop engaging
these types of drugs with respect to
schizophrenia we know that dopamine
seems to be related to the delusions and
the psychotic symptoms and excessive
increases in dopamine activity may be
involved in kind of having an aberrant
salience attribution where individuals
pay more attention to seemingly
innocuous stimuli and that may
contribute to that delusions on the flip
side reductions in dopamine
transmissions may be related to certain
aspects of depression where individuals
might not have the energy and the
motivation to go after good things in
life which is a key symptom associated
with depression do you have any final
comments for us these types of what I
think you know we knew you understand we
love to kind of blackbox different brain
structures this brain region does that
this brain region does that but I really
think as we continue
with behavioral neuroscience and
understanding how the brain control
behavior we have to think of it in terms
of dynamic interactions between
different systems and one brain region
they contribute in a variety of
different manners to control behavior
depending on the different inputs and
outputs it's connecting with and if we
want to understand what's going on
and when the brain doesn't work well in
psychiatric disorders I think we need to
found a firm foundation and seeing how
the brain normally works to solve
problems that gives us greater insight
into your oldest function I'd like to
once again thank the audience for
joining us today
participation we have some questions
that we didn't have time for today but
we will try to address those by dr.
fresco via they have information that
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast and be viewed on-demand
through September of 2016
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
and we encourage you to share the email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye